according to a recent Harvard Harris
poll the majority of Americans now
believe quote Joe Biden was involved
with his son in what is an illegal
influence peddling scheme and yet as far
as we know despite a mountain of
evidence now the FBI had Hunter's laptop
since December of 2019 the FBI and the
doj that refused to investigate quote
the big guy who Hunter complained he had
to give half his income to and on the
other hand there is no shortage of witch
hunts against Donald Trump which we were
talking about a little bit in the last
segment now the 45th president of the
United States is back with us for
reaction all of that this goes to the
heart of Jim Jordan's investigation is
the FBI politicized is the doj
weaponized James Comer's committee
looking into whether or not the Biden
family uh in fact we we know that Joe
lied when he said in a debate with you
and and said it to other press people
when he said there there's I've never
talked to my son about his farm business
dealings we've got photographic evidence
we have dates and times of meetings we
now have according to James Comer
routing plans to different llc's and
money's going to nine separate Biden
family members and they're looking for
one particular document where five
million dollars was exchanged for an act
that they claimed that Joe Biden may
have committed in exchange for this deal
um yet how come nothing happens to them
well they're being protected and it's a
one-sided system it's a very unfair
system but they're being protected look
at the time that Biden said about the
billion dollars to get rid of the
prosecutor now if can you imagine if I
said that a billion dollars to get rid
of the prosecutor you talk about tape
that's on tape that's so illegal what he
said it's America's money we're not
going to give you a billion dollars
unless you get rid of the prosecutor
that was Prosecuting his son and his
son's company even though his son didn't
know anything about energy or anything
else and he's on the board of an energy
company getting paid a fortune by the
way no the whole thing is crazy what's
going on and it's so bad because it
makes them look so bad you know we talk
about borders we talk about elections
but you can add the the uh our justice
system if it's corrupt if the people
think if there's any perception of being
corrupt and when you look at all of this
criminality like the laptop has so much
stuff on it it's so bad it's so evil and
yet they don't want to do anything it
even affected the impeachment because it
Richmond Oaks number one and two if they
read the laptop and they had the laptop
should not have proceeded because I was
right and it should not have proceeded a
lot of people said that but it is a dual
system of of uh government there's a
dual system of
you talk about Law and Order you can't
have Law and Order in a country where
you have such corruption and the
corruption is and they fight so hard not
to give the papers with me they make up
papers they fight so hard not to give a
document now how bad can this document
be and it's very dangerous I think it's
a third point but it's very dangerous
for our country well common said to me
on radio today he has the document he
said on TV last night hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else